hi my name is Mike wills and I'm the web
development curriculum manager here at
Udacity I usually create a new branch
whenever I'm moving on to a different
piece of work anytime I'm doing
something different I will create a new
branch I like to think of it as context
switching
whenever I'm switching to work on a new
feature or whether I'm going to correct
a bug I'll create a new branch at that
time get branches help you keep a
project organized particularly when
you're sharing that project publicly
you'll have your master branch and that
would be your production quality branch
that never breaks always works and then
you could have a development branch
where active work is taking place on
your project then a lot of times you'll
have things like an experimental branch
or maybe some unique feature branches
those are things that you're working on
and fully expect them to break and you
want to share those with the public but
with the understanding that this isn't
production quality work just yet
branches are also good when not only
collaborating publicly but they're
really good to collaborate with yourself
so a lot of times if I'm working on a
feature and then I come across the bug
branches allow me that ability to
context switch and get away from the
work I'm doing on my feature go back to
where I need to be to fix the bug and
then compartmentalize that work branches
are really good even if I get bored on
working on a feature it gives you the
ability to okay I want to switch and
start working on something else right
now